butterflies soar using big wings and  slow flaps about 20 times slower than  the beat of a honeybee to see how they  fly with such odd timing and equipment  scientists use high-speed video to  capture the body posture and motion of  butterflies flying in the lab then they  simulated how each wing bee pushes air  around and how that changes with  different flying techniques it turns out  butterflies rotate their bodies with  each wing beat that waggle helps them  move upwards toning down the waggle and  tilting forward pushes them ahead in  this way butterflies can get where they  need to go in their own jerky erratic  way  you